مدينه ام عباد الكرديه في محافظه اذربيجان
الغربيه في ايران تحولت الى سقنه عسكريه
مع استقدام الامن الايرانيه تعزيزات غير
مسبوقه ومن معهد العشرات من المواطنين في
مدينه مهابات خرجوا الى الشوارع للمشاركه
في الاحتجاجات والمطالبه بتشكيل حكومه
جديده قبيل اقتحام القوات الامنيه
الايرانيه للمدينه حيث قامت بنشر تعزيزات
عسكريه واسلحه ثقيله بعد ما حلقت مروحيات
على علو منخفض في سماءها وقامت باطلاق
النار على منازلها وعلى منازل المواطنين
بحسب مقاطع فيديو تم تداولها عبر من
الصلاه التواصل الاجتماعي اظهرت ايضا
القوات العسكريه الايرانيه وهي تتجول
بالسيارات في انحاء المدينه بشكل مستمر
حيث وصف المواطنون اجواء المدينه بانها
تشبه اجواء الاحكام العرفيه فن تابع
راكان
[موسيقى]
طبعا في اشاره الى تدفق الوحدات الخاصه في
الحدث الثوري الايراني باتجاه المدينه وهو
مرد عليه سكان المنطقه بالخروج للشارع
وخلق ملحمه شعبيه
نظام الايراني دعونا نتابع مشاهدينا بعض
ما يحصل فيماد
راكان
[موسيقى]
وائل اليوم الخامس والستون على التوالي
الاحتياجات متواصله في 30 مدينه ايرانيه
فيما تتوالى ردود فعل الشخصيات
التلفزيونيه على قمع الاحتجاجات الشعبيه
فقط ودع المذيع والمراسل الرياضي داوود
عبيده هيئه الاذاعه والتلفزيون
فقال بان مساهمه في تغطيه خاصه او في
تغطيه خاصه لمونديال قطر ستكون مستحيله
بحجه انه لا يمكن له ظهور بمظهر المذيعه
الرياضيه المفعم بالحيويه وسط المعاناه
التي يعيشها المواطن الايراني الاضرابات
الطلابيه هي الاخرى تتواصل في نحو 50
جامعه وكليه في طهران ومدن اخرى التي تشهد
اعنف هجوم من قبل القوات الامنيه
الايرانيه والتي راح ضحيتها احد الطلاب
واصيب اخرون واعتقال لبعض الاخر
[موسيقى]